[Applaudissements]
il y a les jours cinémascopees il y a
les jours noir et blancs il y a les
nuits ciném mué chapeline petite
fleuriste triste et les nuits
symphoniques chanson d'espoir chanson de
Lara où le film est trop court pour
l'amour qu'on en a j'ai joué à tout cœur
à tout pique à tout vent à tout va avec
les femmes avec le jeu avec le feu avec
moi-même et de Bridan poker je rejouerai
encore souvent à faire la vie à faire
parfois le
mort il était une une fois ma
vie ça commence comme un roman un conte
de fait pour Prince charmand où
Cendrillon pas
suivi où la Belle au bois
dormant dort encore d'un sommeil
lourd une simple histoire
d'amour où la princesse prend son temps
entre les souvenirs à grand spectacle et
les souvenirs séribés les images parfois
se mélange s'échange prennent les
couleurs les unes des autres mais il en
est certaines irremplaça immuable que je
ne pourrais jamais confondre les seules
images du temps auxquelles mon cœur
répondent parfums envolé prénoms effacés
la chaîne continue si l'anneau est cassé
à la première neige tombé sur mes
cheveux j'ai pensé à tes yeux soleil et
j'ai fait un
vœu il est c'est une fois ma
vie ça commence comme un
roman un compte de fit pour prince
charmant où Cendrillon viendra
sûrement oou la Belle au bois dormant va
seraiveiller un
jour une simple histoire
amour viens ma princesse viens
[Musique]
j'attends